you stored in narcos okay and I'm just
curious when you do a show like that
here's what I'd be worried about if I
was doing a show or technically I'd be
worried about hearing from the cartel or
offending the cartel or doing something
that gets the cartel angry did that ever
happen when you're doing that you know a
lot of people were telling me I need a
bodyguard and he had life insurance
stuff like that but you know Colombia's
the most beautiful country
you could go to yeah but one thing did
happen
Pablo's accountant he he wanted some
money and Hubble's accountant felt he
was owed money
a little entitled yeah I guess you could
say yeah that's like guys you can't give
a million dollars this guy's wait he
wanted a million dollars no he said a
billion he wanted a billion dollars
I didn't think Netflix is worth like
maybe they are now I have no idea Oh
network Netflix that's a billion now now
to get to give to the a no just right I
get that out there cartel if you want a
billion Netflix as it but that that's
crazy it's crazy talk
yeah we must be on something that's that
that would but that would get me nervous
like I wouldn't want to make those
people and yeah I'm a little nervous now
telling the story yeah I mean it is an
accountant yeah she's gonna do yeah the
next day look at Sandy's head
that's not I'd be more upset than that I
wouldn't go hey look it's Andy's head
and by the way I got the space work
right I'll be about though yeah that
much around right here thank you
you know your character on narcos steve
murphey do you ever wonder if justin
bieber's current look was influenced by
your character do you ever wonder about
that take a look at this this is it
feels like he's ripping you off it's a
little porn star ass guy yeah no but you
look together and I feel like he owes
you a billion dollars you know and if
someone's gonna give me a billion
dollars might be him yeah but uh yeah he
didn't go full murphy it looks like
shaved the receding hairline in my head
and right in the offseason and narcos
that's not a good look
okay okay so you don't have your key
pine on
you